in five four three two one is it hanging
up on listen we're live live dr. Phil
well I've someone's calling you what's
going on I was trying to find no [ __ ]
out of all the years you've been doing
your show and all the years you begin
advice how did this catch me outside
girl how did this happen out of all the
different shows you made a monster I
know I mean it's my moment of infamy
seriously this girl comes on with her
mother and her mother actually brings
her on a course and if she's a train
wreck and we work with her and we send
her to this ranch for like four months
right she goes for a long time and makes
a complete turnaround does a really a
great job they say she's become a leader
she's working with all these girls doing
a great job and then she graduates and I
remember this last shot when we do this
this piece at the ranch she jumps up on
this fence and he's smiling and
everything and waving it all
one night home with her mother one night
and her mother's finding people that are
trashing her the mother on on these
social media platforms her mother tracks
him down backs into who they are gets
their phone numbers calls them up
yelling into the phone calling them
names and stuff gets the daughter
involved one night crashes so they come
back for a follow up like I don't know a
month or two later and when they come I
say okay we're gonna have them back they
walk out I have the audience completely
empty I have nobody there to play to I
mean 250 chairs empty nobody in the
house but me
mother and the daughter that's a good
move and they go what where is everybody
else well you don't need anybody we're
just here to talk and you know keep
things rolling right and they were
dumbstruck they there was nobody there
to showboat for or play to and there's
like a 15-minute interview they had
nothing to say and off they go and then
this phrase that got turned into a you
know whatever a meme or whatever they
call it yeah it just went crazy and what
she was nominated for a Grammy or sad
Siri I'm serious so I'm I take no credit
or blame you know I just did what I
could and I'm saying you're saying I
wish everybody well maybe she'll turn so
maybe it'll grow her up she'll turn
something positive a but I hope so well
that's a very good attitude very healthy
attitude for you but it is when
something goes viral like that something
strange that for whatever reason it
catches and takes off it's it doesn't
make any sense it's a very weird thing
it makes no sense she's on a billboard
on sunset a giant billboard really huge
enormous billboard it's like one of
those side of the building billboards
will they you know they put the graphic
up it covers the entire building it
makes no sense seriously seriously
there's people curing cancer you can't
find him with both hands exactly nobody
has any idea who won the last Nobel
Prize but you know you know more power
to or I if if she can turn into
something positive
does she have talent have you ever heard
any of her music now I have no idea I've
only seen her on your show yeah I
appreciate you bringing that up but it's
just so strange that one train wreck
could for whatever reason catch on and
then all of a sudden it's gigantic
they say that somebody signed her and
paid your millions of dollars seriously
yes you got like a close to a million
dollars from a makeup company really
yeah well
okay there you go I mean if that's
happening right like what would your
advice be then would your advice be hey
get your [ __ ] together and stop being
crazy well she's making a lot of money
off of being crazy and her opportunities
before that were probably severely
limited well they had to be and what I
hope now that this even though this
certainly is a quirk what I hope now is
that she's surrounded by mature people
with business heads on their shoulders
and development people that will
actually guide this in a way that it's
not 15 minutes right ya never know you
know that's what I hope well everybody
thought the Kardashians were gonna be 15
minutes it's been 15 years yeah but
there's been you know people make fun of
them and there's some good things there
to make fun of they do things to be made
fun of but there's also a very smart
business and branding that's gone into
that as well 100% and you know and I was
actually very impressed with her that
she actually went to the White House to
talk about prison reform right for
people that are unjustly accused and
being been in jail for too long for
things that they didn't do and that's
something she's actually passionate
about yeah and I know Kim and she's
actually a very nice girl very smart and
all in you know as I say they've done
some very brilliant branding and it
certainly paid off it's just so
fascinating when something catches like
that girl what is her name
the catch me a sign girl huh Danielle
bra goalie or something yeah so much
yeah because I didn't know where is to
catch me outside girl but if she didn't
say that one phrase yeah and she just
said that I think to her grandmother or
somebody in the audience I know it
didn't even register with us at the time
wow it was it wasn't a standout phrase
in the interview or anything it just
passed by somebody just grabbed it and
then it became a meme yeah what a weird
world we live in yeah no kidding what is
it I mean it has to be a lot of
responsibility to try to give people
advice and try to straighten their life
out and show them the
the flaws and the errors that they're
making yeah it is and you know people
ask me sometimes they say you know dr.
field our problems do you think problems
are as simple as you make them out to be
and the truth is I don't think problems
are simple at all in fact I think
problems are really most of the time
pretty complex they're pretty layered
they have a lot of different origins and
they're oftentimes comorbid a lot of
things exist together so I don't think
problems are simple at all but two
solutions are often simple don't you
think I mean it's kind of like the old
joke you go the doctor and you say this
hurts and he says well didn't don't do
that anymore
yeah you know it's a lot of times it's
very simple in it somebody will have a
complex thing that comes from childhood
or maybe it's a drug background or
they've had trauma in their life but the
solution is change your behavior I mean
stop rewarding bad behavior choose a
different path in life just behave your
way to success sometimes the solutions
are very simple even though the problems
are very complex because at some point
you have to stop focusing on why and
start focusing on what instead of why it
happened what am I going to do to change
it so sometimes the solutions are pretty
simple but implementing those solutions
are often very it's often very difficult
for people to change their lives change
their patterns it is and in patterns is
the key
you know nobody does anything in pattern
if they don't get a payoff and if you
can identify that that's why that's why
insights so important that's why I think
it's the number one outcome to whether
somebody's going to respond to a talking
therapy for example if somebody can
identify what their payoff is where they
really can figure out I'm doing this
repeatedly and my payoff is I don't have
to work or I don't get held accountable
for this or I'm escaping accountability
over here or I get attention or sympathy
or if they can figure out what their
payoff is
and they can then control that whether
it's for themselves or their kids or
whatever if you control the currency
then you can control the behavior hmm
yeah it's it just seems that people have
they have this comfort in their patterns
and even if their patterns are
self-destructive even it's drug abuse or
alcoholism or did those those the
comfort in those patterns falling into
those patterns
it seems very compelling to a lot of
people yeah and payoffs don't
necessarily mean that it's a positive
payoff right
I mean payoff for taking heroin as you
get high and so you're high for a while
that's not a positive payoff but it's a
payoff right and if you if you get high
and so you don't get a job and you don't
take care of your kids
that's a payoff that you're not doing
things that you need do that you should
be accountable for
it's a pathological payoff but it's a
payoff nonetheless and so that does
reward you even though it's a
pathological payoff it's a pathological
thing you call it a reward and if you
but if you can identify that where they
say look I'm I'm not doing what I need
to do and I need to stop rewarding
myself in that way and hold myself Canty
to be there for my kid I tell my kid I'm
gonna be there every day and I don't
show up because I'm high on drugs then
you know I need to stop doing I don't I
need to not let myself get away with
that and instead require myself to show
up for the kid when I say I do say I
will and then you see what's in the kids
eyes you share the experience with them
now that becomes your payoff so then
you'll start showing it for your kid
yeah how many people take your advice
how many people just listened and try
for a little bit and then bail you know
it's hard to say because I think our
sometimes our most productive guests are
the ones that don't get it because the
mail we get they'll say oh wow that guy
didn't get her - that woman didn't get
it but I saw myself in them
and I'll never say that again mmm
I saw them being such a right fighter or
I saw them being so hard-headed or so
oppositional and I I heard them say
things I've said and they'd left and
didn't get it I got it I'll never do
that again so sometimes those that don't
get it at all while they're there are
the ones that are the best teaching
tools for the millions of people that
are home watching yeah that's
interesting isn't it when you watch
people fail and you go oh okay
I see that in myself yeah I just got to
not do what that guy's do and then also
do you see the stubborn pigheadedness
that some people have what they won't
listen to advice and you could clearly
see how they're ruining their lives by
not being honest yeah and sometimes the
story that we might have is maybe
extreme where you say I don't do all six
things they're doing but I do two of
them and they are in sharp relief to me
so I get that I'm gonna do that anymore
so I mean that's where I think you get a
payoff and you know people go and find
these things on the internet I mean last
year you know we have a channel where we
put up you know different clips and
divorce shows or parenting shows or
whatever and we had over 2 billion views
you know last year people just going and
finding that information and looking at
it so I know people are seeking the
information out and looking at beyond
the show itself you know you know they
must be seeking information and we just
don't have a good distribution system
for mental health in America so I think
they look I think they're hungry for and
they look for it well there's so many
people out there that are trying to do
better they're trying to get their lives
in order and you know shows like yours
and and you know just advice shows
people they're giving out inspiration
and knowledge it's so it's such an
important thing for people especially
for people that didn't grow up with wise
parents or maybe a good support system
around them you know I think that's
that's true and yeah I grew up with a
alcoholic father and it was a pretty
violent home and and he was a really bad
alcohol
and I know having grown up in that you
wind up with what I call a damaged
personal truth and you feel second-class
and the problem that kids make and
because I know I did it and and I and I
see others do it is you compare your
personal truth what you know about
yourself you know how you really live
and what's really going on you compare
your personal truth to everybody else's
social mask because you go to school and
you know well I know that last night the
windows got kicked out of my house I
know that the utilities got turned off
and I know there was a big fight in my
kitchen last night and the kids sitting
next to me he's got on a shirt that's
all ironed and his face is all bright
and clean and you know he looks like
he's just got it all together and you
compare yourself to that person that kid
and you feel like you're second-class
and the problem with that is we generate
the results in life we think we deserve
so if you think you're damaged do you
think you're second class you will
generate results that you think a second
class person deserves hmm so if you
don't fix your personal truth then
you'll spend the rest of your life
saying well you know those really good
results those belong for somebody else
that's not for me that's for somebody
else and you'll settle for second best
and you won't get what you might
otherwise generate for yourself if you
don't fix your personal truth and so I
think a lot of people are struggling
looking for a way to kind of get out of
feeling not good about themselves and
damage self-esteem damage self-worth and
they really don't know where to go so
and that's why I do the show I don't
look I'm not under the misapprehension
that we're doing eight minute cures if
they're mean come on yeah we're not
doing that but I think if you can point
people in the right direction if you can
raise their awareness you can get them
thinking about it you
and create a narrative where they at
least say you know how do I feel about
myself I mean is there stuff I need to
resolve I mean what am I saying to
myself if you can get them thinking
about that then you know maybe you've
done something yeah you know Tony
Robbins once said once that it's
incremental changes over the long haul
and the way you have to look at it is if
these two boats are going in a parallel
direction and one of them just shifts
five degrees over the course of time
this boat is going to be in a far
different place than the other boat
that's going the same way it was always
going yeah and the important thing to
realize as well is the next year is
going to go by whether you're doing
something about your life or not I mean
we're sitting here right now at the end
of February and the next 10 months are
gonna go by whether somebody is working
to make change or whether they're not
and they may think you know oh my god
I'm so far overweight I'll never get it
under control or I'm so behind in my
bills or I'm so you know just depressed
or my everything is so out of control
well you know what you make those
incremental changes and then you know
pretty soon in December you go hey I'm
way better off and I was at the end of
February
so you made little changes and they all
added up and if you don't by the end of
the year you're just getting deeper so
every little bit matters yeah I tell
people to write things down I said one
of the best ways to get things done is
to write things down write down what
you're trying to get done write down
what you need to get done on a long-term
basis and what you need to get done on a
short-term basis and write off a
checklist force yourself be accountable
yeah the difference between a dream and
a goal is a timeline and accountability
yeah
accountability is gigantic you got to
have somebody whether it's yourself or a
friend or somebody that's gonna say look
did you do what you said you were gonna
do by this time and if you don't hold
your feet to the fire because I mean
just sitting around dreaming some day
someday I'm gonna get a different job
someday I'm gonna change this well
someday in a day of the week
you know there's Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday are you saying
look on your counter some days not on
there so you got to say okay I'm gonna
take this small step buy here this small
step by there this small step by there
and then pretty soon you know we don't
leap tall buildings in a single bound we
take it a floor at a time that man
although all the years you've been doing
your show you've developed a real
community right I mean you you you
really have made an impact if you stop
and think about all the people that your
shows touched and all the people that
have listened to your advice and all the
people that have taken that advice and
and made those little incremental
changes in their lives and set those
goals and held themselves accountable
that's a pretty significant thing well I
hope so I mean I I think I know that
there's a stigma attached to mental
illness and that really bothers me there
should not be
I mean having depression or anxiety or
whatever to me should have no more
stigma than having a knee injury or
kidney infection or diabetes but there
is yeah a stigma attached to it and I've
tried to talk about this in a way where
it's okay to talk about it and not be
ashamed of it it's it's okay if you've
got anxiety you got PTSD whatever it's
okay let's talk about it let's get help
for it get it behind you and move on I
mean it's not it's not something that
you should be ashamed of what do you
when you're talking to someone that
maybe has depression do you try to get
them to exercise first do you try to get
them to visit a psychiatrist immediately
and get on medication like do you take
it on a case-by-case basis well I do but
you have to approach it everybody has a
philosophy about it and I'm not saying
that mind's any better than anybody
else's but I do have a philosophy about
it and I'm very slow to medication I
mean I think you know I think you use
medication for biochemical replacement I
mean if for some reason your body is not
making enough of something it needs
then maybe you support it short-term
biochemically but you know I I look at
depression I think there's a lot of ways
you can break it up but I look at it
like is it exogenous depression or
endogenous depression I mean is it
coming from the inside out
or the outside in is it because you're
reacting to something I see a lot of
depressed people that in a sense it
makes sense right
I mean you look at their life and you
say well if you're not down about this
you should be
I mean you've lost your job you've
gotten a divorce
your health is in the [ __ ] you're I
mean you should be down about this it's
external things so you don't need a pill
I mean put somebody in a chemical
straightjacket because their life's
falling apart what the hell is that
gonna do yeah but that's just putting
goggles on them where they can't see it
I would much rather get them to behave
their way to success and say what are
you reacting to that you're depressed
about let's put that on a to-do list and
start like you said write it down and
start crossing those things off let's
figure what's an action plan to change
this action plan to change the next
thing actually and then when you start
doing that then you generally see their
mood lifts a lot of people that are
depressed or just realistically reacting
to a crummy circumstance in their life
it's not necessarily a mental illness
it's just a realistic reaction to a bad
spot in their life
yeah that's such a way good way of
putting it to that is you weren't in a
bad state looking at this it might be
something wrong with you yeah you're in
denial yeah I mean if if you've gotten a
divorce lost your job your health in bad
shape
your kids are alienated from you and
you're saying I'm fine then you're not
in touch with reality right you should
be bothered by that and and I think to
give somebody a pill to mask your
feelings about that just keeps you off
task I don't your pains a good motivator
you know I grew up in like Texas and
Oklahoma and I don't know you've ever
done this but we were I used to spend my
summers in the thriving metropolis of
Mundi Texas you ever heard of Monday
Texas now it's mu in its a you not an O
em you nday
it's got like 2,000 people in it but in
the summers it would get hot in Mundi
Texas no when I say hot I mean you look
out in the backyard and your dog burst
into flames that's what I'm talking
about so we would be going to the
swimming pool or something barefooted
and you get halfway across an asphalt
road and you look down and you're I mean
like holy [ __ ] mean your feet are just
on fire so what are you gonna do I mean
that is painful you're gonna do one of
two things you're either going to make a
u-turn and get your ass back over to the
side of the road and get in the grass or
you're gonna run to the other side and
get off the road and get in the grass
but you're not going to stand there in
the middle of the road and melt yourself
down to the knees pain is a motivator
pain is not necessarily always bad if
you're in pain it's gonna motivate you
to move to change something and to match
that with drugs to dull that pain with
drugs it's not necessarily a good thing
that is wise wise advice and I wish more
people thought that were particularly
more doctors you know I have so many
friends that have gone to a doctor
because I'm not feeling so good and
they're almost immediately wanting to
throw them on something yeah like not
smart all the years you've been doing
this have you noticed like was
depression as prevalent like the term
depression or what it doesn't I mean I
don't really remember it being a thing
when I was a kid that was discussed the
way it's discussed now now it's
discussed the way people discuss all
sorts of other ailments is it just an
awareness thing or is it just people are
thinking about it now in different terms
well I think it's part of the narrative
now and I think with social media with
the internet not just social media but
with the Internet I think there's just a
lot more
it's a lot more in the nomenclature and
there's a lot more awareness about it
but I think it was just as prevalent in
the 50s and 60s as it was now but in the
50s and 60s there wasn't a psychologist
on every corner right and there is now
yeah and there wasn't sub doctoral
licensing then I mean you what does that
mean well back then the you had to have
a PhD or an MD as a psychiatrist to see
patients now they have marriage and
family therapists they have licensed
social workers they have different
levels where you can do independent
practice so that's broadened the number
of people that can provide services and
some people think that's a good thing
some people think it's not I generally
think it's a it's a good thing because I
think 58% of our rural markets today
have no psychiatrists available and
something like 50 or roughly have no
mental health professional available at
all none so there's just nobody
available to help people in in the
outlying areas so I think the more
people you can get into the profession
so long as there's a degree of
competency is better but you know I
think it's always been prevalent I just
think people didn't talk about it very
much it's just something they swallowed
or they took to church or ya know when
you see you know these all these folks
that are on medication today
I mean how many of these people do you
think legitimately should be on
medication I mean is it something you
can assess you know I I can't answer
that in terms I mean I'm sure there's
research of people how many people are
on medication but in my personal
experience most of the people that I see
on medications in my opinion don't need
most of the medications they're on now
and that's just anecdotal it's my
opinion you asked me to handle your
research
survey or study to support that I can't
hand it to you or I can't point you to
one I just tell you
after 45 years in this experience I see
people that are on medication they've
usually seen someone for six or eight
minutes and said you know I'm really
feeling kind of down or blue yep here's
some Prozac here's this here's that they
give it to them and they don't even
really ask why and they just give it to
them because medicine has become a
high-volume business and that's not
necessarily the doctors fault I mean the
way that it's now funded and Medicare
and Medicaid you got to turn them and
burn them and yeah or you can't stay in
business and so it's a high-volume
business and so they throw pills at them
because they don't have an hour to sit
down or don't take an hour to sit down
and talk about say well let's find out
what's going on is there a reason like I
said if this guy's got five parts of his
life that have gone down or a woman it's
got you know three or four areas of her
life that have really gone down in in
quality then they should be having poor
mood
so why mask that let's come up with an
action plan and change it so most of the
people I see on medication not all but
most of the people I see are on too many
medications in too high a dose or either
don't need it at all and I'm really
bothered by polypharmacy that's where I
really get frustrated yeah this is I
think what you're saying is a very
common-sense approach but it's not the
norm today no it seems like more people
are treating this you know air quotes
depression issue as if it's a medical
disorder like like diabetes or something
when you need medication yeah and look
for a lot of people it works I mean yeah
you give people a mood elevator and they
say hey I feel better and then maybe
they change their life maybe they move
their life into a more positive
direction they can wean themselves off
of it because one of the things about
depression for example you're using as
an example is you get what's referred to
as psychomotor retardation there's a
there's a lessening in activity level
and I think old sayings get to be old
sayings because they're profound like
you're not going to get a hit if you're
not swinging mm-hmm well if you're
depressed and so you think slower less
actively you behave less actively your
chance of getting rewarded goes down
right you don't get out there and you
don't mix it up socially as much you
don't apply for jobs as much you're not
as productive on your job as much so
you're less likely to get strokes less
likely to get rewarded well maybe you go
take a pill and it lifts your mood up so
you get more active and so now you can
start getting Pat's on the back you
start getting people to engage with you
more so that lifts your mood and that
takes care of it so you took the
medication short term you're lifted back
up and you're okay short term it can be
an alternative but I've seen people on
everything from opioids to mood
elevators for years and that's where you
lose me yes don't get it yeah I know
people that have been on things since
they were 5 years old yeah and they're
in their 40s yeah and then you have
wastebasket diagnosis like a DD and ADHD
where you know what used to be a spoiled
brat is now a DD or ADHD right oh they
start prescribing these ritalin
neocortical stimulants like ritalin and
if you give a kid that does not need a
neocortical stimulant a stimulant you're
really going to throw them off the
charts now because you're you've got a
normally active brain that you're now
making hyperactive so you're creating a
problem that didn't exist before you
gave him the medication because you
didn't do the proper diagnosis yeah I
had my old neighbor had a situation like
that they had a kid and the kid was just
had a lot of energy and they weren't
paying attention to him and so they
started medicating them it's insanely
common yeah
and you you cannot chemically babysit
your children and who knows where these
kids are gonna be 20 30 years from now I
mean we're just looking at you this rash
of people being treated these ailments
air quotes and then we're not seeing how
this all turns out in the long run and
how much damage we're doing these people
know and in fairness on the other end of
the continuum I have seen some people
that are clearly psychotic schizophrenic
delusional that without medication are
absolutely impossible to manage but if
you put them on antipsychotics and so
you can lower their delusional behavior
their hallucinatory behavior so you can
now have a meaningful conversation with
them so they can respond to talking
therapies it makes all the difference in
the world and without those
antipsychotics you would be little lost
yeah without them so there are some
medications for some disorders that are
absolute miracles that without them you
wouldn't be able to do the work you need
to do to get the person back where they
need to be yeah unquestionably I mean
there's definitely a lot of great
pharmaceutical drugs that help a lot of
people do you get pushback from a lot of
these positions from the established
medical community you know sometimes but
you know mostly when you talk to people
about it thoughtfully they agree with
with what I'm saying I mean most people
will agree that you need to be
thoughtful about prescribing medications
and that medications are too readily
administered I mean that's certainly
what we've seen in the opioid epidemic
right now opioids are so readily
prescribed right now that there are
enough opioid prescriptions for every
man woman and child in America to have
their own bottle
and if you renew that prescription one
time one time if you are taking those
opioids at the seven day mark your
chance of being addicted at one year is
one in 12 and if you renew it at if
you're still taking them at 30 days your
likelihood of being addicted is 1 in 3
Wow
and these things are getting written
with way too high a pill count and it's
and so the addictions we're seeing a
whole different kind of addiction now
coming out of the suburbs and they take
him for a while and they're very
expensive and after they take him for a
while heroines cheaper so they dumped
the opioids and start taking the heroin
so you're saying soccer-mom heroin
addicts that you weren't seeing 10 years
ago because they get started on
prescription opioids and then they can't
afford them or finally the doctor cuts
them off but they're addicted and so
they start taking heroin because it's
cheaper no this is obviously a very
disturbing pattern but where do you see
is going like when you look at the
future and it looks bleak in that regard
I mean I've known several people that
have had real problems with pills you
know the problem that that I think
people have is they think because a
doctor gave me this because it's on a
projection pad that this is safe and
your body doesn't know whether you got
that in the back alley or you got it
from a doctor it still has the same
addictive quality and I think it is at
an epidemic level and I've testified
before Congress about this and I think
there are several levels of
accountability at the manufacturing
level and at the prescription level and
at the educational level so people
understand I think everybody has to take
part of it and I'm doing everything I
can to raise the awareness about it as
well when you testified before Congress
what was the reaction they're very much
aware that this has become a serious
serious problem because the the cost
as as you see the lost labor in the
workforce is in the billions of dollars
you see the the demands on the
healthcare system that this is creating
young mothers with with children and
babies born addicted to these opioids I
mean the numbers are just going through
the roof so I mean it's putting a strain
financially on the healthcare system
that it just can't stand so you start
costing money and it starts getting
politicians attention so they start
saying okay now we got to start doing
something so they get it they get that
there's a problem what could they do
though once there seems like once that
genies out of the bottle well clearly
you've got to start educating people and
the manufacturers have to be required to
start labeling this much more clearly
physicians have to be much more
conservative in prescribing you know I
just had this shoulder surgery and I
took like one one opioid one pill they
gave me in the hospital and after that
you can manage it with like Tylenol or
something because the surgeons now are
so good with the arthroscopic surgeries
and stuff it's so it's so much less of
an insult to the body that was ice and
tylenol stuff you can manage it if you
just kind of focus on it a little bit
and and I'm not saying if you've had
surgery and you're having organic pain
for God's sakes get ahead of the pain
and stay ahead but when you as soon as
you can get off of it get off of it and
understand what's happening yeah there's
no sense being like macho we don't need
a leather strap between your teeth and
you'll have some surgery I mean should
if it hurts take the pill get past it
but realize the minute you can get away
from that you need to get away from it
but you know they don't need to give you
a 30-day supply right they need to give
you three or four days and then
you got to go see your doctor again and
if it's still a problem discuss it I
mean that's what that's what I think
needs to happen is just be a lot more
conservative about what your giving is
the problem is these pharmaceutical
companies make so much money yes you
don't want to they don't want to back
off that they got private jets and
yachts to pay for yeah and they're
starting to shut down some of these they
had some of these pill clinics in pain
clinics in Florida mm-hmm where you
could go in without an x-ray without an
MRI and just say you had back pain and
there was a doctor there that would give
you a 9 account prescription on the spot
no questions asked 90 mm-hmm and you're
out the door and you go down straight to
the next one
yeah because there was no database no
database and that doctor might be a
foreign doctor that flew in from
offshore wrote all the prescriptions
during the day flew off again at night
and now they're shutting that stuff down
so that the hammer is coming down well
one can only hope when you've been doing
your show as long as you've been doing
it and I'm sure you you've made it a ton
of loot what makes you want to do a
podcast why doing that well my interest
has been you know it's saying there are
a lot of people getting their
information on the Internet by getting
clips of the show and that sort of thing
and it's clear to me that is the
population is changing you know I'm an
old guy but younger people are getting
their information in different ways you
know going to the Internet and the
digital menu has got to be readily
available and you can reach a lot of
people that way that you wouldn't reach
the other way there's a whole population
that's not going to watch broadcast
television during the day yeah and
there's a whole population that's
watching broadcast television earing
today that maybe isn't on in the digital
space and if I can get a crossover
between the two and you can get a bigger
audience to spread your message then you
know that's what you're doing my goal is
to spread
the message and get what I think is
important to say out there so I mean
I'll shout it from the rooftops if
that's what I can if I think that's
effective I want to do anything that's
scalable to get the message out there
and and to me I'm doing I'm doing some
different things in the podcast and I'm
doing on the show on the show I've got a
fact pattern in front of me I've got a
story I got a family got an individual
that's got a specific fact pair and I'm
dealing with that fact pattern in the
podcast I'm not solving a problem I
don't have somebody there that has a
problem for me to solve I'm just talking
to people that I find interesting and
I'm able to talk to them about whatever
I want to talk to them about and discuss
things like you and I are talking about
right now I think this is I think what
we've been talking about is an important
discussion and I welcome the opportunity
to have that discussion and I don't have
time to do that when I'm talking about
somebody who's sitting there saying you
know I I think my kid is on the
precipice of overdosing or is really in
trouble and I got to focus on that I
don't have time to pontificate about
such things as the opioid epidemic or
the philosophy of pills versus therapy
and things of that nature because I have
to give all my attention to the story in
front of me in a podcast environment
like we're doing now I can talk about
things that I think people need to hear
I think it's if they don't they don't
have to listen but if they if they're
interested it's there so I like it being
more freeform and me being able to talk
about things I've been talking about
what makes people a champion like I
talked to Tony Romo right after the
Super Bowl about you know you came from
Eastern Illinois University it's like a
what nine students or something he's a
little bitty University and he turns out
to be quarterback of America's team for
14 years set all kinds of records and
then goes to the booth and becomes a
number one color analyst in television I
mean champion champion champion you
why you know what is it what do you
attribute that to I like asking those
questions yeah hearing people talk what
do you say to young people about that
what made you a champion are you gonna
let your kids play football with all the
CTE and stuff what do you say I'm out I
like having those kind of conversation
did the same thing with Shaq and Charles
Barkley and different people what did he
say about what makes you a champion you
know for him he said that he has this he
says he didn't he wasn't the kind of
Swagger sort of person that you know
came in cocky like he was gonna own the
field and own the game but inside he
said he had this absolute Drive that if
he didn't win he couldn't live with it
it's like if somebody thought like he
played the game somebody beat them beat
him that just the idea that that person
went home thinking that they were better
than him that they could beat him that
he just couldn't eat sleep think until
he got back and owned it again and got
back to it he said he's just drive to
win and so he would mean he said he
would be out at one o'clock in the
morning in the dome throw in a pass that
that route got intercepted he got jumped
on that route and you'd be trying to
figure out why on Thursday in practice
he saw what he needed to see why didn't
he see it on Sunday and he would analyze
and analyze and analyze until he could
get there until he could do it until he
could win it he just had this drive to
win that super unhealthy obsession they
all share that Michael Jordan had that I
mean we've talked about that several
times on the podcast so many people that
are extreme winners they're psychotic in
their obsession with winning yeah that's
all they want to do and if they lose
they they they it's almost insufferable
they almost can't deal with it yeah and
I I don't know if that's necessarily a
bad thing but the diff
prints between winners and losers his
winners do things losers do not want to
do yeah they they will get up in the
middle of the night they will do this
they will do that they feel it more they
just do things losers don't want to do
they'll pay a price losers just don't
want to pay yeah and loser says it's not
worth it and every winter has been a
loser oh that's what made him a winner
yeah
if all you ever do if it's a if you go
through life is in a success only
journey god how boring would that be I
mean you think it would be great but I
keep not ice cream every meal about the
fourth meal you're gonna be thinking God
let's kill something and eat it well
it's like what were you talking about
about depression about that bad feelings
will motivate you to change if you're in
a bad feeling if you're if you're in a
bad state in your life that pain is an
amazing motivator and even though it
feels terrible at the time it can propel
you to a new and better life because you
don't ever want experience that again
and make you grow and be a better person
yeah and you got to decide what's your
currency I mean because you say you know
you've done your show a long time and
probably don't need the money
but there are different kinds of
currency right I mean you don't always
work for one kind of currency I mean
every year when we wrap our season I
kind of take a month and let everybody
go unwrap you know just kind of unwind
and relax and kick back and do whatever
they want to do and then we start
meeting and focusing on okay how can we
reinvent ourselves for next season how
can we tell our stories better how can
we broaden our horizons do things
different so that we raise our game
because we're kind of competing with
ourselves there's you know we're kind of
a category by ourselves we're the only
one that does what we do and we've been
number one for a long time because I got
a really hard-working team but we're in
us nobody else tries to do what we do so
we're kind of competing with ourselves
and so we work real
hard to figure out how can we have a
bigger impact how can we tell this more
effectively what techniques can we come
up with that make this even more
powerful more impactful than what it is
and that's what you know that's what
really gets me moving well it's very
telling it's mean that's why I would
imagine you move towards doing a podcast
where it's less restrictive and more
open-ended and you can kind of do
whatever you want but it's that's pretty
cool that all these years of doing that
and giving out advice you still find
this this passion to make it better and
to do it from a different angle yeah and
you know I'm as excited about we're just
about to wrap you know our 17th season
17 seasons and that's a lot how many
episodes you done coming up on three
thousand and I did Oprah for five years
before cool and so that's that's 22
years and then your watch and then I
just renewed for five years moved out to
2023 taped before you sign that like
what am i well just go fishing you know
Robert and I thought about it but well
what am I gonna do I mean I don't but
you enjoy it obvious I do yeah I enjoy
it you could tell and you know I've
always told my team the thing that we
don't want I don't want to get bored
right and if it gets formulaic for me
it'll be formulaic for the viewer and I
don't want that to happen and you know
we do a lot of news stories and stuff
and that keeps it fresh because you
don't know what's going to break in the
news tomorrow right and so we do most of
the really big news stories and we don't
break the news stories we go behind the
headline talk about here's what really
happened you as Paul Harvey said here's
the rest of the story yeah just what you
read in the headline now here's here's
the rest of the story and I really like
doing that I really like getting into
that well and when you're doing this on
your podcast one of the beautiful things
about that is that you know you can
explore these ideas without commercial
breaks you don't have to
have anybody telling you what to do you
could just look whatever is interesting
to you is that how you pick the subjects
and the people that you're talking to
yeah like this week I had on Pam Myers
who wrote live spotting I've spent a lot
of money is that a book on liars my
spotting yeah and I've spent a lot of my
career on deception detection because I
spent a lot of time in the litigation
arena own interrogation techniques
that's how you met overwrite yeah yeah
it was when she was doing that uh the
the beef industry was suing her yeah the
Mad Cow case in Amarillo yeah yeah she
got sued for a couple of billion dollars
and I've represented her in that case
and that's that's how we met and I mean
I had Pam on and we've both worked a lot
in deception detection and interrogation
techniques and stuff and so just and it
came right at a time when you know Jesse
Smollett is in the news about is he
telling the truth was he not telling the
truth and then here we have this
conversation what did you think
immediately when you heard that story I
was very suspicious when I heard this
yeah Jaime and I we shut that once the
cameras are off like he's off [ __ ] that
guy that is real that nobody it was just
too much like a movie yeah it was a bad
movie yeah I mean it's nine below zero
and two people are lying in wait just in
hopes that he might come by 2:00 a.m.
yeah I mean so strange you know it was
suspicious and you know he's entitled to
due process and he's gonna get it yeah
he's gonna get it now he's saying he has
some untreated drug problem so he's
trying to carve out some path to explain
his bizarre behavior but there are very
there are very specific live behaviors
that people can't really control like
what kind of stuff well for example when
when people are really desperately
trying to convince you they're telling
the truth
they'll do a lot of times what are
called convincing statements rather than
just telling you what they did or didn't
do they'll do convincing statements like
you know me I like somebody saying who
somebody stole the petty cash in the
office I think you know me I give more
money I donate more money than was
stolen yummy you guys know me I mean I
was Employee of the week class you know
there's convincing you there's this nice
guy and that's not what someone does if
they're wrongly accused no what did
someone do if they're wrongly accused if
they're wrongly accused
they'll look you straight up in the eye
and tell you I didn't do it and if you
ask them what do you think should happen
to somebody that did an innocent person
will say I think they should be found I
think it should be held fully
accountable to the extent of the law
somebody that's guilty will say well you
know I don't know I mean people make
mistakes you got to give a guy a second
chance do you worry that in coaching
that you're essentially coaching Liars
by telling people this kind of stuff and
someone who does steal the money you
know would be able to kind of like hey
it's not for amateurs and when you there
are some things that you can tell people
to watch for but one of the things you
do if there's somebody that you suspect
is you increase their cognitive load
during the interrogation and there's no
way you can prepare for that oh how do
you do that well you plan a mind virus
for example Who am I in virus I like it
yeah this is a Perry Mason type [ __ ]
yeah like what'd he do like if let's
pretend some money's missing yeah and I
said to you is there any reason somebody
would have told me that they saw you
near that cash box about the time it
went missing dump dump town
okay now people talk at 125 words a
minute they think at 12 to 14 hundred
words a minute now if it takes you five
five seconds to tell me no you took the
money who because if you were nervous
right now
if you didn't take it you know you
didn't take it you don't need to run
scenarios through your head to think who
could have seen me you know I was I
didn't see anybody know what he could
have seen me what do you know but if you
didn't do it it doesn't take you one
millisecond to say absolutely not have
you ever been wrong before where you see
someone on television you go I think
that guy's guilty and they're innocent
or vice versa
oh sure because if if you really want to
know for sure if somebody is guilty or
innocent you need to invest a lot of
time you need to get a baseline on what
they normally look like talk like feel
like and then bait and in knowing that
baseline you didn't need to compare how
they're behaving on TV so just walking
by the screen and seeing it you might
see things that would ordinarily belie
behavior so it could just be part of
their personality so if you're going to
really make a judgement you got to put a
lot of time in and figure it out and
what you should do before you decide
you're gonna be a human lie detector is
do your homework and you know try to
figure it out objectively before you
figure it out behaviorally
I mean you ought to do your
investigation find out if somebody took
the money and you know find out where
they were and you know look for
fingerprints and do this and do that I
mean you ought to really objectively
figure it out before you rely on these
things and so unless you get a baseline
and get one-on-one with them and spend a
lot of time then you can't be you you
can't be really certain that you know
whether they're telling the truth or
whether
it would be fun if it was that easy and
that some people are pretty obvious yeah
I heard a cop once say that when people
are guilty they tend to plead and cry
and then when they're not guilty they
tend to get angry when they're accused
people that are wrongly accused are
generally irate from the beginning till
the end I mean the every case is
different but if you're wrongly accused
that person is going to be pissed off
from the minute you accuse them till the
end because it's like I'm their self
righteous like I didn't do this and
you're saying I did and screw you yeah
and they don't take a step back and when
you you see people they do these
convincing statements and they're
pleading for you to believe them and
then and and anytime somebody says now
in all honesty usually the next thing
out of their mouths a lie like no no Joe
honestly as opposed to everything else
you've been telling me I mean why are we
we're bracketing this one out is all
right or if they invoke the deity oh I
swear as my good god yeah God as my
witness mmm and you know I don't know
whether I have not done what I said you
need to do with Jesse Smollett but I do
know when he went to the set at Fox he
said you all know me I swear to God I
didn't do this
mmm and I mean they were like three or
four those kind of statements in like
two or three sentences there well my
favorite one was on stage who called
himself the gay to park that's enough
for me that's a little narcissistic it's
a strange thing though like there was
another one today a guy lit his house on
fire
and think in Chicago
and said he's a gay fella said it was a
hate crime
and they caught him it's a lot of that
going on you know a lot of fake crime
very strange the the then then sometimes
people accuse people of something and
someone will say why would why would
someone make something why would someone
turn themselves into a victim what
there's a lot of clout and being a
victim especially today there's a lotta
you get a lot of attention a lot of love
I think there's a lot of false
accusations and false attacks and it's a
lot of real ones but man when the false
ones combo it just does a giant
disservice to everybody
well there's a fair amount of research
as to why people do these hoaxes and
particularly hate crime hoaxes and one
of the primary motivations of course its
sympathy and attention and all that but
one of the interesting reasons that I've
read in research is that they really
feel like it's emblematic of how the
system treats them overall this is just
a dramatic example of it they feel like
I'm treated this way anyhow so they're
just I'm discriminated against I suffer
bias I'm put down this is just a focused
example of that so I'm really not lying
I'm just role-playing how I'm overall
treated oh wow
so they justify it in their mind if
they're just gonna bring all this
treatment into one example to bring it
into focus and so while it's a phony
deal it really is truthful
representation of what their life is
really like they justify it in that way
oh how weird you know that's yeah that's
a deep psychological [ __ ] out there no
that's that's stretching that's a weird
one we like when you've write it out
like that put it in your mind that way
yeah wow it's strange too because it
gives people this this is this giant
public show to watch now you know and I
hate that family what a talented young
man I mean isn't he
times that I've seen I don't watch that
show a lot but the times I've seen him
on there singing and assuming it is his
voice and he's singing extremely
talented young me I find a lot of
talented people are [ __ ] crazy
well you know somebody said that
somebody said that the really talented
singers and actors were the weird kids
from high school that we're in drama and
all sure though yeah
various levels are crazy obviously not
all deceptive but you know some of the
most brilliant actors are just
completely out of their mind and that's
one of the reasons why they're so good
at acting is because they can look my
frame wet my friend Wayne Federman had a
bit they did about it on stage and he's
like guess what it's not [ __ ] normal
to be able to just cry yeah he goes you
could just cry and pretend something's
wrong and cry is that's crazy these are
crazy people yeah and and you really
can't go to a certain place you've you
don't have a little of that in you yeah
my dad used to always say when he's
working with patients you would say
there's something about that old boy I
can't stand about me you say you can't
see it in them if you don't have a
little of it in you yeah oh there's a
hundred percent truth than that that is
the thing that drives me the craziest
about weak people I'm so terrified of
seeing weakness and and and just just
just just being pathetic I'm so
terrified to seeing that in myself I see
it in other people it's just it smells I
smelled like a drug sniffing dog like oh
there it is yeah you smell desperation
yes what makes you do this why are you
doing a podcast I have always been a
blabbermouth I can never shut the [ __ ]
up I love talk and and I've always been
fascinated by human beings and their
lives and just talking to people and
finding out like the guy before was this
guy Yohan Grillo who's a narcotics
journalist he's a narco journalist in
Mexico I mean I couldn't wait to talk to
that guy oh yeah let me just what a life
he's been living in Mexico for 18 years
is from England I'm I still alive don't
alas that's something right there you
and you know he's telling me about
friends that have been killed and you
know he's been in some sticky situations
a few times and you know I'm just
fascinated by pip by people and what
they like to do you know I'm fascinated
by athletes I'm fascinated by physicists
I just always been very very curious and
I've always recognized that everyone
thinks about things differently and that
I could take a little bit of something
from everybody whether it's from a book
or it's from have a conversation with
someone I can gain a little bit of a
little bit of experience a little bit of
knowledge a little bit of insight yeah
you're naturally very curious because I
listened to you interviews and you're
naturally very curious you don't
struggle for the next question because
you really want to know something that
makes it much easier there's very lucky
that I found this yeah very just
stumbled into doing this kind of [ __ ] no
it wasn't this way in the beginning in
the beginning it was just horse [ __ ]
with friends and it's slowly but surely
as the pot the podcast became popular I
was like I wonder if that guy would talk
to me and then I would get people on and
then it became more of these long-form
interesting conversations yeah yeah and
if you're curious about human
functioning at all human nature at all
there's an endless menu of things you
can talk about I don't care who it is
you could you could pull somebody out of
a car on the street yeah and if you're
curious you can talk to them because
everybody has a different take in life
everybody has a different walk yeah
absolutely and what you're talking about
you're interviewing all these athletes
you know I think people tend to write
off athletic pursuits as being entirely
physical and they are not I mean I think
this is an easy way for people to look
at it that don't engage or they've never
really thought about playing anything at
a very high level that it requires some
intense thinking it might not require
mathematics or a large vocabulary but
understanding what's required
understanding when and how to execute
understanding how to keep your [ __ ]
together under pressure those are all
intensely intellectual aspects of any
really high end athletic pursuit and
there's a different breed of cat that
wants the ball with
- buzzer yes and it's not just a
showboat there's a different breed of
cat that once that ball at that point
yeah and it's not always who you think
but it takes a special kind of person
that wants that pressure yeah that knows
they can handle it better than anybody
else yeah you know and it's a lot of
times it's people that are entirely
confident that they've done the work you
know there's a haunting thing that
happens with athletes where you're not
sure if you did enough and in fighters
it's a very dangerous inclination
because it leads you to over train and
you have to be very careful about that
because with a fighter you only can
learn so much during your training camp
like say once you get into training camp
you got eight weeks depending on who you
are some guys like to do a little longer
but the average is maybe eight twelve
weeks is a long camp you already have to
know how to fight by the time you get to
camp so what you're really doing is just
kind of working on specific movements
where you're dealing with one kind of
fighter and then getting your body in
shape getting your body condition -
getting your mind ready preparing
everything cutting your bodyweight down
getting so you can weigh in and have a
good amount of just you got enough
vitality can't drain yourself so this is
complicated dance that goes on and that
haunting thing of did I do enough can
cause fighters to screw themselves over
by overtraining yeah so you have to have
enough confidence to know that you've
done enough as well as enough you have
to know you've done enough but no you
haven't done too much this is really
strange dance you know and this this
weekend is a giant UFC big UFC two big
title fights between four of the very
best fighters in the world and I mean
that is one of the most interesting
aspects of the fight game to me is one
watching these guys stare each other
down at the weigh-in where they get a
look at each other than they know 24
hours from now they're going to war and
just see like is there just us mellowed
out is there anything is there anything
in there you know and just knowing that
this is probably one of the most
difficult things in all of athletics and
that these guys are going
there they're gonna ply their trade and
one of the most complicated things it's
a battle of physical mental of mindset
of will of conditioning and discipline
and then it's also there's a lot of
random [ __ ] that happens do you think a
fight can change at a weigh-in when
people are looking at yes yes you think
it yeah it can change it can shift right
then it can't change forever but like
you could look at John Jones sideways
upside down you could stick you to it
ain't gonna affect [ __ ] there's some
guys that are just locked down and
bulletproof
John Jones is bulletproof there's
certain guys that was just bulletproof
they just look at you and like they know
what to do there's a reason why he's
undefeated you know he's just he knows
how to do it but then there's other guys
that like that maybe like maybe it's
80/20 maybe and then the the staredown
you look at the guy and you're looking
at my god damn and I'm fighting Yoel
Romero how the [ __ ] did this happen and
then you see him drop down to 75 maybe
73 percent confidence 72 70 [ __ ] they
look at his traps he's got a neck that
starts at the top of his head you like
off [ __ ] you know there's certain guys
they're just they're intimidating at
weigh-ins - yeah yeah it can change a
little bit but not for everybody there's
certain guys that just it doesn't matter
you can't get in there there's certain
champions like real champions like
Mighty Mouse Johnson there's a bunch of
guys like that that are just champions
you look at them it doesn't matter they
know what they're doing they've done the
work they're the best in the business
like you can mean mug them and get
aggressive they might smile at you then
way this is cute try to make me nervous
hilarious see you tomorrow yeah so is
that because they know who they are and
it doesn't matter who this is or is it
that they just don't they don't believe
in this guy it's they know who they are
I think and they have reached a level of
confidence when you get to a certain
level of success like you know John
Jones has one loss in his records by
disqualification a fight that he was
destroying the guy and he was hitting
the guy with it's a really dumb rule but
when you throw elbows you're not allowed
to
throw a 12 to 6 elbow meaning coming
straight down the only reason that
exists is because when mixed martial
arts is first being was first being
sanctioned by athletic commissions the
the people that were in the Athletic
Commission had some nervous fears of
they had seen like those late-night TV
shows or karate guys are breaking bricks
with their elbow
driving straight down they thought they
could kill somebody if they did that so
let's not have we'll eliminate that
strike it's a dumb move and John Jones
hit this guy with a couple 12 to 6
elbows and he was disqualified in a
fight he was just just destroying the
guy so for a guy like that who has this
staggering resume of achievement he's
widely considered to be the greatest
light heavyweight champion of all time
if not he's definitely in the running of
the greatest fighter ever of all time
for a guy like that he's not he's he's
confident to the point of you know he's
he's he's not trying to just beat this
guy although he's going to beat this guy
he's trying to go down in history as one
of the Great's of all time what the
greatest of all time so for a guy like
that it doesn't matter what you do he's
not that he's a Michael Jordan type
character you know there's a few of
those guys out there this these LeBron
James is these Larry Bird's they exist
in all sports they they have this
mindset a champion mindset does he find
angry or does he fight business like
business like he's very businesslike
yeah he's very businesslike he knows
what he's doing
the best guys fight business like
there's some guys that fight with
emotion and they're still really good
but like Fedor Emelianenko his famous
Russian guy he would he would have a
look on his face that he was cashing a
check and he was smashing a guy's eye
orbit in you know he was just uh you
know he was the highest level of that
like that
robotic businesslike approach to
fighting and then after he'd knocked
unconscious he'd help you get back up
yeah it was over once he shut it off it
was over there's no no sign he thought
emotions were weak like showing emotions
in a fight showing anger all that was
weak yeah I think there's a huge
psychological component to it I mean I
agree completely
giant gigantic I think if you I think if
you go in with doubt
man I think that's terrible terrible
yeah thank you
just now you're fighting yourself and
them to remember the Mike Tyson fights
when he was in his probably you know
remember looking those guys faces oh
yeah they're staring across the ring and
I'm like oh Jesus what did I sign up for
yeah I don't know what the money was
here but it wasn't worth it this seemed
like a good idea at the time was a
life-changing life defining moment when
when you were staring across the ring at
Iron Mike and it was like 1989 who's
that top of the world yeah and and he
and you knew he's gonna come over there
and it's you like never been here before
yeah
guns blazing yeah and he dude yeah and
he did yeah meanwhile you meet him now
he's like the nicest guy on the planet
Earth yeah couldn't be a sweeter guy
yeah I talked to me today he's got a
daughter that's apparently a pretty good
tennis player really and he's really
behind her now and focused on that that
was him back then because when he came
out of jail he's fighting Peter McNeeley
yeah just letting him know it's comin
baby yeah but you know he was never he
was never as formidable after jail as he
was before he went ya know well there's
a ton of factors his training was never
the same
you know he didn't he lost that
connection with cus D'Amato you know he
had custom auto with training him when
he was at his very best and then Kevin
Rooney who worked with customer and Mike
trained him after that and then they
eventually parted ways and that was
before the Buster Douglas fight remember
he had guys in his corner didn't even
have an ends well
I mean his eye was swelling up and they
didn't even have ice to put on it yeah
yeah there was a lot of factors but also
you know when I talked to Mike on the
podcast one of the things was and this
was just him sort of coming with to
grips with the fact that he never really
had a childhood his childhood was from
the time he was 12 years old custom
model took him in was hypnotizing him
and teaching him how to fight teach
amount of fighting and hypnotizing him
to be a machine his going you know he
was literally saying to him you don't
exist the task exists the job at hand
exists and and you're gonna go out there
and you're going to get the job done and
he was telling this to a
thirteen-year-old that never experienced
love he just was abandoned and homeless
and and this is the only way he ever got
any sort of positive reinforcement in
his life is by destroying people yeah
yeah and that's sad but you know now he
seems to really be connected to his
daughter I mean you see a you see and
hear a softness in his voice he really
is connected yeah he learned you know I
mean it's easy to try to look at someone
like who they were you know 20 years ago
it's it's easy to do that it's easy just
oh he's that guy but people evolve and
they grow and he's a great example of
that he's a very different person you
know he doesn't even work out because
he's worried about his ego like he he
doesn't hit the bag or do anything like
that it's occasionally get on the
treadmill and work out a little bit on a
treadmill just get a little exercise in
he's worried about feeding his ego was
worried about like looking at himself in
the mirror and bringing that old monster
back again really yeah that's what he
said oh yeah I think you'd be afraid of
not being able to get back to the level
he was I don't think he's afraid of that
I don't think he wants to be that guy
yeah he says he doesn't like that guy
which is crazy because that guy's who
made him rich and famous and everybody
loves him because he was that guy but
who he is now is a completely different
person just a sweetheart a real
sweetheart yeah he seems like it I mean
you'd never think to talk to him if you
didn't know his history you'd never
guess that was that guy yeah
no you'd never would yeah I think the
psychological aspect of fighting is one
of the more intriguing parts of it to me
and you know for me it's like probably
one of the reasons why I got interested
in psyche in the first place and the way
people think about things and and
weakness like real weakness weakness
weakness can get exposed in a variety of
different ways but in competition is
when you really see it yeah I'm one of
the I have this theory you know and we
see it in sports and I saw it when I
talked to him it he's been a friend of
mine for a long time and I was talking
to him about his psychology as he goes
into the football
he says he plays a movie in his mind of
the entire game before he plays it
because you know in a football game
you're gonna have 11 or 12 possessions
during the game you just throw out the
football game you can get that ball 11
or 12 times and you'd say and I'm gonna
carry that ball three or four times per
possession and he knows which plays he's
gonna run he would run him through his
head he would see it he would know who
was gonna be there to tackle him he was
you know he'd run everything through his
head and he's one of those guys that
wants the ball when the clocks running
in yeah but I have this theory that
situations do not make heroes situations
expose heroes hmm and I saw that in
Katrina the hurricane that so devastated
that that one neighborhood what Ward was
it the ninth war and I forget which Ward
it was that got so wiped out when
Katrina hit New Orleans and there was a
guy down there that had been really
quiet nobody had ever heard anything out
of him he was an older guy lived in a
house stayed to himself and that night
when the water was at rooftop level I
mean he swam rooftop to rooftop and save
six seven eight people got him out of
there
and he didn't make it out but he got
seven or eight people out of there and
you go back and you check his history
and he was a military hero he just set
quietly in his home and when the
situation came about it revealed who he
was you know I think that's what happens
I think if you've got a hero they just
sit there sit there sit there until a
situation reveals who they are I don't
think it makes them a hero I think it
reveals that they're heroes and I think
that's what happens to people they they
are who they are until they get and then
the opportunity to comes along and
they're going to show you who that is
they may show you they're a coward or
they may show you that they've got the
focus to hang or they may show you that
they're a hero but life circumstances
are going to come
we're gonna show you who somebody is
yeah I completely agree and I think
what's also interesting is when someone
does get revealed to be a coward they
can become a hero it's very hard it's
very hard to get past the memory of you
being a coward well and I'll tell you
why I think that's true if you want to
know please I mean maybe you don't going
off on a tangent come on no I think I
think we learn about ourselves and you
know everybody talks about self-esteem
and self-worth but nobody ever talks
about what it really is or how we get it
and I think I think about it in terms of
self attribution because you know how
you form opinions of other people like
if you look at this guy
and you you maybe you work with this guy
and so you watch him across a couple of
years and maybe this guy shows up to
work every day and he's there fifteen
minutes early and he unlocks the place
gets everything ready puts the coffee on
has his desk ready he's all buttoned up
and man when the bell rings he's ready
to go and you just learned that this
guy's buttoned up ready to go dependable
never misses he's always there so you
attribute certain traits and
characteristics to him based on your
observations of him and your experience
of him based on that you assign certain
traits and characteristics to him but I
say that's exactly the same way we form
our own self-image and our own level of
self-worth we watch ourselves go through
life and we watch how we handle certain
circumstances and situations and that's
why I say overindulgence is one of the
most insidious forms of child abuse
known to parenting it's not the worst
it's just insidious because if you
overindulge your children and do
everything for them you never let them
observe themselves master their
environment you never let them step back
and say wow I did that hmm I built this
I overcame that
handled this I did that and so we that's
the same way we make our own self-image
and level of self-worth we watch
ourselves overcome the third grade we
watch ourselves stand up to a bully we
watch ourselves handle a test with the
information that intimidated us or we
watch ourselves make it on to the little
league baseball team and actually get a
hit when we needed to or we watch
ourselves get on to the debate team and
actually argue something successfully
whether it's academic or athletic or
musical we watch ourselves do it and so
we go back and say hey I did that I
attribute to myself the ability I can
hang I can do this I can rise to the
occasion or we watch ourselves fold like
a pup tent in a windstorm and say you
know I can't hang out I don't have it
and we make those attributions to
ourselves and so we shrink from the
challenge for the rest of our lives
until like you said it's hard to
overcome that and something pushes you
up until you finally observe yourself
overcome something and I think that's
how we form our level of self-esteem and
our identity about who we are and I
don't think most people think about that
you look back and say okay how did I how
did I get to be Joe Rogan as I sit in
that chair you have a self-image you
have a level of confidence and ego
strength a level of self-worth that's
attributable to things you've watched
yourself do or not do achieve not
achieve overcome or whatever throughout
your life and and I think to know
yourself you have to know what those
things are I think you're a hundred
percent right and I think for children
participating in things that are going
to test you is so critical giving them
this opportunity to realize that the the
there's a line between success and
failure and that you could push through
that line you could you could become
successful at something and watching
kids that's what I think sports are so
important for children I think and
that's one of the more insidious things
about having these participation trophy
for kids worth it nobody wins the game
yeah everybody plays but nobody wins we
don't keep score
why the [ __ ] you plan yeah I mean that
dish goes down as an environmental
non-event yeah I mean that contributes
nothing to your definition is just
something to do it's also
psychologically it's coddling it's very
it's very damaging for your potential
education that you would get from that
situation the bad feeling that you get
with someone scores on you is motivation
for you to be better at defense yeah you
know I think we cheat kids when we do
that and of course you got to play
everybody I get that not everybody is
meant to be an athlete so okay look do
something else yeah be good at what
you're good at and if you really want to
do it well you've got a long road it's a
greased hill yeah start running yeah
everything's not for everybody so find
what you're good at and watch yourself
achieve in that Lane you know that's
like I could I can't carry a tune in a
bucket okay I can't even I can play no
instrument I can't sing I can play a
radio if it's got a big on/off knob
that's it and so I don't try I mean
that's I'm just not good at that so I go
into lanes that I can do stuff and
observe myself in that but I think you
cheat kids if you don't let them observe
themselves face adversity and overcome
it absolutely and it's also an
interesting lesson to learn that life
isn't fair I mean if you're a kid and
you're playing basketball with a 15 year
old LeBron James and you're my height
you go huh yeah this ain't gonna work
out at all
yep you're looking at a towel boy here
this is not [ __ ] happening yeah and
you have to be able to understand that
and appreciate that and then conversely
if you're very physically frail you know
maybe wrestling's not for you either you
know maybe maybe you we need to do
something about your body before you
engage in any sort of a combat sport you
know they did an experiment back in like
it was the sixties they did something
called teaching machines have you ever
seen that no it was a short
your time but they they took students in
the class where they put the steps of
learning the information so close
together that there was never a failure
experience it would say like the war of
1812 happened in 1812 then the next
thing would say the war of 1812 happened
in Blanc you Phil in 1812 I mean come on
potted plant could get that right so
they've put it together and you they
would teach the information and they
would teach it to criteria where you
mastered the information you had it a
hundred percent and they said wow this
is great
everybody learned it so everybody made a
hundred everybody got the information
they truly did learn it there was no
question about it they learned the
information and so they did great and
then they took him out of that program
and put him back in the regular
classroom and the first time they came
to questions they didn't know the answer
to the first time they didn't get a
hundred they came apart like a cheap
suit they panicked they didn't know how
to handle adversity they didn't know how
to handle it when they didn't have the
right answers they didn't learn how to
not be perfect and so they scrapped the
whole program because he said you can't
do this because that's not the way life
is right and if I mean it's you're not
teaching how the real world works you
might as well teach them to go on red
and stop on green and then give them the
keys and put them out in life because
that's not the way it works and those
kids were absolutely screwed up when
they got into a truly competitive
environment you can't be success only
yeah it doesn't make any sense it's not
healthy it's not good for you you don't
learn from it I mean if the whole idea
about school is you're supposed to be
setting kids up for the future he's
supposed to be teaching them not just
information but teaching them how to
learn and how to improve yeah and that
worries me I you know I've read that
story not long ago when these students I
think it was at UCLA in law school
complained and got a professor either
disciplined or fired because he required
them
take a counter argument over something
controversial like Ferguson he said I
want you to you know I know you that
you're all on this point of view now I
want you to prepare an argument for the
other side
hmm and they all said that's that's
upsetting to us we just can't do it and
they went to the administration and
complained wow that's crazy because you
may have for you as a lawyer you may
have to represent someone who's done
something you don't agree with if that's
what you want to do for a living right I
mean are you kidding me they were like
needed therapy I'm like what the hell
has happened here
oh my god that's so crazy yeah that's
nuts that's crazy you know yeah well
there's a there's a movement going on in
this country right now that the social
justice movement and it leans in that
direction that people don't want to look
at things for how they are they want to
look at things for how they want them to
be yeah that just I just don't
understand you you cannot legislate that
everything is going to be equal for
everybody because everybody's not equal
I I'm sorry they're not equal they may
be equal in terms of their value as a
human being yes but they're not equal in
math skills they're not equal in how
fast they run they're not equal in
creativity they're not equal everybody
has their own value but that doesn't
mean they're marketable skills in an
open society in an open market are going
to be the same no it's ridiculous I used
to have I had a joke and one of my
special so two specials ago about there
was a story about a woman who was
guarding the White House she was the
lone guard at one of the doors of the
White House and some crazy man broke in
and knocked her to the ground and just
ran through the White House and he was
running around inside the White House
for like three minutes before they
finally some off-duty US Secret Service
agent tackled this guy I saw like what
the [ __ ] is going on this guy's running
through the White
tackle this guy and that the joke was
that people think that a woman can do
everything a man can do I go a woman
could do everything a man could do is
that true and some woman he was Lin that
crowd that Comedy Store was like yes I
go well that doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense here's why it doesn't make any
sense because a man can't do everything
a man can do I go look I've met
Shaquille O'Neal and his dick is where
my face is and if the White House is
experiencing a Shaq attack I'm the wrong
person to save the world because he's
gonna run right over me I go but if my
wife and kid we're guarding the White
House guess what I'm getting in okay I
love my family but if it's between me
and get like there's no way they're
gonna be able to stop me I love them to
death but I'm a man and they're women
and if there's a woman guarding the
White House I don't care who she is I'll
[ __ ] her up it's not gonna happen this
is crazy but this someone had this idea
that they would put a woman in charge of
a very physical job you should have a
giant man with a violent temper and he
should be armed okay cuz this is the guy
that's keeping bad people from the
[ __ ] president yeah I just I don't I
don't understand it just seems like you
got to find your own lane I mean yeah
you don't want to put me in the NBA
well yeah physical things in particular
women and then there's also mental
things look I suck at math okay if
everyone has a chance to work at CERN
right everyone has a chance to work at
the Large Hadron Collider including
people that have no idea about physics
we're gonna have a real time making
these equations work yeah that's what I
mean about finding your own lane like
you I can't add two and two and get five
every time I'm just not good at math but
I'm good with words I can talk I can
read fast and I can comprehend well but
I am NOT good with math so I got myself
into a Lane where I talk for a living I
read I talk I see Alice a teef not
quantitative I can accept that I'm not
suited for that I mean that I don't feel
bad about myself because of that once
you do something and you're good at it
you can accept not being good at other
things it's much easy
if you find a thing that you're good at
whether it's gymnastics or singing or
painting whatever the [ __ ] it is if you
could find a thing that you're good at
it'll make you it'll give you a feeling
of self-worth and you won't need to be
good at everything yeah you can accept
and you can enjoy other people being
good at things as well yeah you know I
said earlier my dad was an alcoholic and
I would compare myself to that kid
across because I had a damaged personal
truth but I found a currency because at
that time in my life I was a pretty
decent athlete for this small school I
was going to so that was my currency
yeah so now it didn't matter what was
happening at home because I got strokes
for being able to jump high and run fast
at school so that became my currency so
now when I compared myself to him okay
maybe my home life wasn't as good as his
but I could run faster and jump higher
so that became my currency so now I ok
that leveled the playing field for me
yeah and you all would like you said
find what you're good at at a given time
and do what you're good at
yeah find something you love find
something you're passionate about and
that you could also excel at and if you
can work it out where it's your vocation
and your avocation you love doing it and
you get paid for it then you're just
double blessed yeah you got it right
because you enjoy doing this and it
works out and that's good yeah you catch
lucky breaks yeah if you but that's boy
that's lucky yeah it is and if I just
think if you're in your life and there's
you don't have something that you're
passionate about I mean and I don't mean
that in a cliche way if there's not
something where you wake up every day
and there's nothing in your life that
you're excited to do man you need to go
back to the drawing board yeah because
if all you're doing is just grinding it
out you get up every day go to a job you
don't like do tasks you don't care to do
and come home to a home you don't want
to come home to and wait to get them do
it again the next day you're burning
daylight what the hell
existence is that yeah I just
I don't understand that that find
something now I don't care if it's
gardening or music or art or athletics
or something find something you're
excited to do yeah expose yourself to
different things with that very purpose
of finding something that you love
there's something out there yeah there's
something out there I guarantee you
something yeah there's something healthy
it's not illegal it's not gonna be high
risk there's something you can do that's
not gonna kill you or put you in jail
that you can be excited about yeah and I
think it's one of the most important
things to do when you're a parent is to
try to expose your kid to as many
different things as possible
to find those things for them yeah and I
got two boys as you know and you know
one of them really well and I did that
growing up because my dad never took me
hunting a single day in his life he
never took me fishing a single day in
his life he never took me camping a
single day in his life he never took me
to the lake he never took me skiing and
boating anything so iris ought to all of
those things you know I had no clue what
I was doing but I took him turkey huntin
duck hunting deer hunting skiing snow
skiing camping I did it all and to see
what they liked let them pick ya and boy
when you don't know what you're doing as
a dad that's a [ __ ] yeah I mean just
little things like you you go camping
and you don't realize that sitting your
tin up on the side of a hill even if
it's like eight or ten degrees is a bad
idea yes Lee you've got to get on flat
ground it looks flat to me but I spent
the night trying not to roll down a damn
hill it doesn't look like it was on a
slant but it was but you figure these
things out as you go along but I was
glad I gave him those experiences so
they could choose and they did and
they'll end this summer that they like
some of it they didn't well I don't know
both your kids but I love Jay yeah yeah
Jay loves you he really enjoys spending
time with you guys and traveling with
you guys and yeah we've had a bunch of
great trips yeah
he's an awesome guy it really has so
much fun yeah
he knows how to have a good time and he
says the same thing about you he's you
know how to have a good time yeah yeah
well listen man tell people how to get
old your podcast we're gonna get it well
it's fill in the blanks and that's ph IL
in the blanks and yeah i guess you get
it everywhere podcaster gotten right
yeah nice tunes all that jazz
iTunes Apple stitcher all the different
places there it is right there oh yeah
you handsome bastard yeah look at that I
mean how about that nice I'll do cleaned
up pretty good don't see the good thing
about being bald is you look the same
all the time yes that's true and you
save money on shampoo you save money on
shampoo and I've been bald since I was
like 12 so really I my hair fell out
really early Wow I remember playing
college football I'd take my helmet off
and it looked like I had an animal in
there what my teammates say what the
hell is in your helmet it's my hair shut
up I don't know why but it just fell out
I guess it got knocked out
well the mustache works too yeah well
some a lot of guys can't rock a mustache
I'd look a little creepy with one yeah
well I try to keep it where it doesn't
look like total porn how do you do that
you gotta embrace your weaknesses you
know I mean I remember when I wrote my
first book on Oprah she said you'll you
won't have any trouble finding it's got
these big old bald head right there on
the front of it so I figure you know
he'll make it a trademark right for went
hard on you yes the beginning I got no
complaints
yeah oh I hear you she treated me pretty
right yeah it worked out great hey
thanks for having me on my pleasure you
got to come to mine absolutely all right
all right thanks man dr. Phil ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]